welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and it's time to open
Pandora's Box as we dive into Avatar the
way of water in this new video we're
going to be breaking down the characters
plot and also the ending James Cameron
has also touched on some things to do
with Avatar 3 and 4 and in this video
we're gonna be going through it all this
is going to be one of the big movies of
the year so if you don't want anything
ruined then I recommend that you turn
off now heavy spoilers from here on out
and if you enjoy the video please hit
the thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the way
of water
strong heart
okay so when we last left Pandora we
just seen the US military being
overthrown by the navi due to slowly
switching sides and leading an uprising
after the defeat of Colonel quadrich the
humans were forced to flee Pandora and
there has been peace on the planet ever
since then we learned that Jake has
created a family with materi and he's
also adopted the Son of God Rich who had
to stay on Pandora born in Hell's Gate
he was too young for cryo sleep and
therefore couldn't return home and has
remained behind with the navi he's not
the only person they've adopted either
and they've also taken Curry under their
wing who's quite a mysterious character
voiced by Sigourney Weaver there's a big
question mark over how she came to be
but the first part of the video we're
gonna be going through that now if you
cast your mind back to the first movie
you'll remember that Sigourney played
the character Grace who died whilst
transferring her mind into her Avatar
just before her death Grace told Jake
that she was with ayor and she passed
away leaving her Avatar body behind who
discovered that Kerry was born from her
and though Grace's Avatar was rendered
brain dead it was still naturally alive
she conceived Kerry who now carries
human traits and these include eyebrows
as well as four fingers now this was
something from the first movie that the
avatars carried and this is because they
were all bearing human DNA Kerry has a
strong spiritual connection to the
planet and this is likely due to gray
seeing anywhere before her death Kiri
even Witnesses Grace at one point in the
film but we don't learn too much about
how she was conceived Kyrie's deepest
wishes that she could have met Grace and
she often visits her Avatar and also
watches through recording she left
behind now due to her body being brain
dead there's three ways that she could
have been conceived the first is pretty
[ __ ] and I don't know if we're
necessarily gonna be going that route
because I doubt Cameron's going to touch
that especially not in a Disney movie
the second option is that Kiri is
actually an Immaculate Conception and
that she came to be after Grace came in
a presence with the God she has a way to
tap into the spiritual side of things
and I think that she may become a really
important character in the upcoming
movies there's always a talk that she
and Norm had thing and that she was
pregnant before she passed away which
means they were getting it on in their
Avatar bodies Kerry can also control
Planet animal life underwater and if she
can do this then it's possible she can
do it with the trees and animals on land
now Grace isn't the only character who
finds New Life in the movie and both
Wayne Fleet and Colonel quadrich return
once more we discover that just before
his death the quadrich uploaded his mind
emotions and everything that made him
him he has been processed through the
recombinant program which has allowed
him to return once more now due to him
being duplicated before his death
quadrich doesn't have any memory of his
because technically from his perspective
he never experienced it there's lots of
interesting things that they can do with
him and potentially he may come to
realize that he's a slave that's simply
being used by the Army rather than
actually having a life of his own
there's lots of deeper questions here
such as what it means to be human
whether a perfect duplicate becomes that
or if it's simply a copy he also hated
the Nabi but is now himself become an
Avatar and the dislike for quadrich is
quadrich coming from him a quadrich
quite richet that's that's my one bad
pun for the video now it's very much a
ship of this year's situation that they
could end up exploring in future movies
as we know that the character is gonna
be back for all the sequels now because
of when he was uploaded he also carries
the same hatred for Jake that the
original did to him Jake is a Trader
that destroyed the hopes of Humanity's
survival and with depleting resources
back on Earth Sully Doom the entire
species because he needed some blue cat
lady his words not mine
foreign
[Music]
land we get a one-year time Jump and we
see as Jake and the navi have started
launching Guerrilla attacks on the
humans spider is captured early on by
quadrachina's forces and realizing that
he has Intel that could endanger their
people Jake and the family decide to Up
Sticks the humans have a way of
basically seeing someone's Thoughts by
putting them on a what's basically an
MRI machine on drugs Jake would likely
be aware of this and not want to bring
his family into it and therefore he's
just like we need to get out of here
because they're using the Twirly Whirly
machine and they travel out to them at
kaina who have become almost one with
the ocean and the Aquatic Life that
lived there the movie is basically about
Jake and the tiri's family learning to
adapt there and navigating how to best
handle a human threat it's very much a
fish out of way of water story and much
in the same way that the first movie
focused on Jake learning something new
the family now have to learn something
new in this new environment now along
with spider and Kerry natiri and Jake
have three other children or
took for short and I'll be calling them
tuck because I butchered all those
pronunciations and in this movie we
watch as they all start to integrate and
also meet several of them at Kaine this
includes Elite tanawari who's voiced by
Cliff Curtis is also his wife Ronald who
I think it's pronounced Ronald who's
played by Kate Winslet and of this the
pair have a daughter Raya who sort of
starts a Thang with Jake's son now
Winslet said that she'd never work with
Cameron again after this she got put
through on Titanic and she stated
interviews that during production she'd
sometimes wake up wishing for death yay
well she's back because I backed up the
money truck and Winslet actually set a
world record for the movie whilst
filming the underwater scenes she held
her breath for over seven minutes which
is amazing but Cameron wanted eight so
get back under the water you [ __ ] a
quadrache in his forces use spotted to
track down Jake and they also start
hunting tolkiens and we learn what the
humans are really there for these
animals are extremely intelligent and
inside them exists a fluid that
completely stops all aging within humans
humanity is now whale hunting them and
trying to harvest this in order to sell
it on to stop humans dying the humans
and attack leading to the kids being
captured and a big battle on water takes
place they managed to escape with spider
but Nate I am a shot jumping off the
ship he ends up dying from his wounds as
his body's taken to the shore and he
very much becomes the first Blood In The
Family the ending of the film someone
acts as a mirror as we start by
chronicling the birth of him and we end
with the character's death now
throughout the movie we saw Jay giving
his children a hard time due to the
pressure that was caused by the humans
coming back he had to turn them into
soldiers rather than letting them be the
family that we see them being in the
opening of the movie Jake's kids were
also bullied by the Met Karina I think
he feels like this war has taken away
the lives that they should have had
together now back on the shore to make
matters worse quartridge has Jake's
daughters and he wants to trade his life
for theirs surrounded by fire Jake and
the teary head out into the night under
the sinking ship along with spider a
launch an attack that wipes out a lot of
the humans with interior almost becoming
fearile as she takes them out Jake
freeze Turk but kiri's taken hostage by
quadrich and at this point the theory
grabs spider and puts a blade to his
neck though quadrich initially pretends
to not care about him dying he hands
Kiri over when he realizes she's willing
to take her son for his son clearly
quadrich cares about him and we'll talk
about this more later on in the video
now Jake goes to leave but quadrich says
that he won't stop until he kills him
and his whole family thus he returns to
battle him again and the family are
forced back onto the ship as the fire
from it starts to spread it slowly
starts to go down and in the end Jake
seemingly drowns quadrach into the water
but he's rescued by spider Jake nearly
drowns too but lurk travels back down
there to get him and they make it out
with some help from a Tolkien and one
land a quadrich called spider certain
and asks him to come with him but spider
does the navi and swims off back to his
family this great impression and this is
very much a sun for a son but rather
than killing spider they've taken him
away from his father he may never know
the love that having a family brings and
will likely spend the rest of his
existence fighting in this War the movie
ends with a funeral at Sea and we know
from the first film that the navi have a
circle of life in which they're born
before they return to Iowa the sun
returns to the spiritual world and Jake
offers to leave them at kaina but he's
embraced by the group and this now
becomes his home the movie ends with
them reaching out to AWA no water and
Jake experiences seeing his son along
with materi Jake vows not to let
quatrich take his home now going forward
they'll make their stand there the movie
ends with his eyes opening and this is
much in the same vein of how the first
film climax 2. going forward there's a
fair bit that we know about the rest of
the Avatar films Avatar 3 was filmed
alongside this movie with principal
photography on it starting back in 2017.
all the cast returned and it has been
stated that quadrich will be the villain
in three four and five una Chaplin and
David dulis have been added to the
cast's new characters and we know the
former will be called varang as with
doulas we don't know his character name
but he did say that he needed to do
motion capture for the movie and has
stayed in passing that his character is
one of the navi you also have Michelle
yo who will be playing Dr Karina Moog
Cameron has stayed in interviews that he
got some notes back for the Avatar 3
script he said that he must have gotten
better because all he got for Avatar 4
was an email saying this is [ __ ]
crazy the title for the third film will
be the seed Bearer four will be called
The Token Rider and lastly 5 will be
called a quest for Ewa we've caused me
the tolkiens in the movie and these are
the giant whales that live within the
ocean we see Jason riding them and
they'll likely become something that the
other navies learned to ride just like
how in June we had the worm Riders I
think that the Tolkien will be a similar
sort of thing these great beasts will
even the playing field in the sea and
allow the navi to take down the humans
the humans of course want them too and I
think that they'll become the utmost
important thing due to the fluid within
them now Lassie is the Quest for ayor
which will be coming out in 2028 I'm
guessing that this last film will have a
strong focus on Kerry due to her
connection to Grace who she connected
with in the movie she can pretty much
become the human personification of aor
and it seems like when she was uploaded
into the tree that she remained there
rather than moving into her body like
Jake did we'll also likely learn who
carries true father is even though I
think we'll go with the whole Immaculate
Conception thing now tying back to
earlier in the bed and the idea of
cloning and so on I do think that they
could potentially start exploring this
Avenue more and more although it's
possible that Jake will kill the second
version of quadrich I actually think it
would be more interesting if he was kept
alive say that he comes to accept the
idea that he's actually quite Rich
rather than being a clone and instead of
living in existence based around War he
decides to try and form a relationship
with his son he has seen behind the
curtain of what humanity is up to and
being a navi now might make him start to
see empathy when he's murdering people
that look like him therefore he may
leave the service in order to live in
this paradise nights with his son
instead of being like nah we're gonna
burn it all down now what would the Army
do at this point well they still have
his mind backed up and I think it would
be crazy if they just decided that
because the prior version had failed but
it was time to create another REM com
using his mind there's no rule that we
can't have two REM coms of the same
person running around out there and for
this newer version it would be like he'd
just come off the back of uploading his
mind he could have two visions of
quadrich running around with one having
gone through an entire character Arc
whilst the other's coming fresh off
having just been resurrected I think
this would add such an interesting
Dynamic to the entire franchise and ask
what it means to be human now we know at
some point that the fight will likely be
taken to Earth the rumors around Avatar
5 say that we will be journeying to the
planet now this could either be because
they want to stop the humans once and
for all or potentially Pandora itself
could be inhabitable The Walker
potentially destroy all life on the
planet Amina the navi have to flee into
space then Abby don't really have the
technology for space travel and thus it
is interesting to think why there'd be
any other reason for traveling to earth
now if you saw the Extended Cut for the
first movie then you'll know that we
spent some time on Earth and that takes
me into my next point which is my crazy
theory about Jake's brother that's right
you chump it's
your favorite bit it's your favorite bit
isn't it you love it it's
so if you cast your mind back to the
first movie then you'll know that Jake
only got into the Avatar program because
his twin brother was part of it Jake's
brother died and thus he was asked to go
out to Pandora as he'd be compatible
with his Avatar I think the recombinant
angle adds a lot of avenues to the movie
and I'd love it if we have a Twist where
it turned out that his brother was still
alive his body was cremated but if his
mind was duplicated then there is the
potential that they could bring him back
with him being a twin as well Jake
lurking at him in his Avatar would add
an extra Dimension to all of their
interactions Jake would pretty much be
faced with the way he used to look and
his brother would represent the past
that he left behind Jake's brother's
death is what pushed him on this journey
and though I don't think they go with
that it could add some internal conflict
within him and his brother I think the
film in general could end up being about
freeing those trapped in the recombinant
program because those that are in it
could potentially be enslaved who knows
how many times quadridge has been
brought back and if one awakens and
doesn't act the way they want they can
just press press the reset button and
start all over again say the use of
fluid and tokens on the soldiers then
that means quadridge is gonna be a slave
that's fighting the war for eternity it
removes freedom and those that don't act
the way they want are forced into a life
of war and Vengeance might not happen
but that's enough
[Music]
anyway I've seen some people saying that
due to Cameron's comments about four
being crazy that they could even do some
wild [ __ ] like saying it's all a
simulation when dealing with host bodies
and stuff but with the title of the
fifth movie having that aware in it I
doubt they're gonna do it movies that do
that stuff without the premise already
being built in normally get backlash for
it and I'd kick the [ __ ] off if that
happened so don't [ __ ] do it and
that's what my thoughts on the film I
think James Cameron he's bloody done it
again in terms of visuals this movie is
unmatched and even the first one doesn't
come close in terms of environment and
the beauty that's on display here it
really is an experience that leaps off
the screen and continues to remind me
why Cinemas are such an important part
of our culture now the plot is a little
Bare Bones and clocking in at over three
hours I think there are some people who
might struggle with the pacing it's an
hour into the movie before we even get
to the mechaina but I think just how
much the world absorbs you definitely
makes up for it again this is unmatched
in terms of scope and scale well and
it's something that I definitely
recommend everyone checks out in a
cinema I just in the same way that the
first movie was captivating this UPS the
stakes too I have seen people saying
that the characters are a little shallow
but I do disagree with that too I mean
they're not massively complex but it's
very mudgy Coming of Age story for the
kids and the parents also having to
weigh up the costs of War you also have
some really interesting things with
quadrach and Kiri that no doubt will be
explored in future sequels down the line
so yeah Cameron's done it again he's
created an amazing spectacle but at the
heart of it it's a story about family
that appeals Timeless now whether this
tops the first one's box office remains
to be seen and I think this does very
much feel like a metal chapter or
whereas that was more Standalone you
kind of need to get all those people
back but I think Word of Mouth for this
movie will be very strong and people
will probably return I also think that
on the whole that most will enjoy it too
now as an experience I'd say this is a
10 out of 10 Twitter Force however as
two other fours however as a movie I'd
probably market around the 8 out of 10.
that sort of place there's great
storytelling and things that set up the
future but yeah the pacing at points and
the fact that it doesn't feel like a
complete story just knocked it down from
being perfect for me now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are a competition right now and
giving away Dawn of the Dead and Black
Adam to three subscribers on the 15th of
January and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie
repeat the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now save that to
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the insane details in
Avatar which will be linked on screen
right now we Revisited the first movie
in the lead up to this and found lots of
cool details so definitely head over
there right after this without the way
thanks for sending you the video I've
been Paul you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace